what is it what is it that you think is
happening in the mind of a guy because I
know there's a lot of dudes like this
what do you think is the thing that's
happening that makes them want to just
impregnate everybody you know that like
that because cream pies feel good dude
[Music]
so
this is kind of a fit of what do they
call it when like something happens and
then like you did something [__] up in
the past but then like now it's caught
up to you what do they call that Karma
thank you so a New York fertility doctor
who is accused of using his own sperm to
impregnate several patients has now died
in a horrific plane accident no way what
is that is that is that really Karma
though because I think Karma would be
like now you gotta pay child support and
you lose everything or like five other
people get him pregnant or something you
know yeah that's more carbon Away Steve
what karma is
are you sure do you want to bet on
anything yeah all he did was die yeah
that's it check this out I want him to
die horribly here's where the karma
comes okay let's go let's go okay he was
flying
in a hand-built airplane that he built
oh but it makes it cooler so it's just
him pretty cool that's really cool so
guess how he got his own sperm he jacked
off in a cup with his hands oh guess
what he built this plane out of his
hands
it is
yeah you're right hey you know what I'm
sorry I I jumped the gun on that yeah
because he was so shaky he's like I've
been jerking off so [__] about so
many years I can't get these rivets he's
flying the plane and then he sees this
one bolt on the left
feels tight
what I have to be hand built why oh he
lost a wing dang dude that's [__] up
how many how how many kids is he
responsible for I know there's like a
ballpark right yeah so he was sued a
couple times
um by the daughter of one of his
patients right uh who got pregnant in
the 1980s and the lawsuit said that he
secretly used his own sperm while
telling the patient the donor had been a
local medical student
he also he's winking did he did he shift
his eyes while he said him she said he
couldn't she said he could barely
breathe because he was laughing so hard
no no so he kept the secret even after
the daughter his biological Offspring
became his Gynecology patient what
so he was like seeing his kids he was
hands on with everything yeah what the
[__] dude dude wait so how many how many
kids did he have it doesn't say how many
was it a fertility like Clinic it's
probably like a hundred so she so the
the girl involved she is linked to at
least nine and a half siblings what the
[__] yeah I remember that story uh yeah
wow they're saying they could literally
be like an uncountable amount because
well when they do the 23andMe won't they
be able to catch catch them all
that's you know like when you when you
uh when you go to McDonald's and all
your friends are like hey get us some
ketchup and you got to get a bunch of
those things
yeah
imagine doing that for like eight years
just like
um ladies were coming into the fertility
Fertility clinic and they're like you
know I want a six foot man strong and he
goes I got just a guy for you he was
like a medical student so everyone
thinks like yeah man I'm gonna get a
tall athlete I'm really into black guys
and goes I got the right man for you and
they're like how come my baby's white
and [__] well he's he's white right yeah
well he's already gonna fit what most
people are probably asking for
a white doctor I think white is like the
most requested sperm does it really
yeah this guy definitely in his head was
like I'm the best candidate I mean if
it's the most right swiped on Tinder
it's probably the most requested sperm
too that's probably where it comes from
huh because you hear about this [__]
happening because most people going to
the clinics are probably white too yeah
so well look it's our biological
inclination to want to spread our seed
everywhere we can which is why he did it
yeah yeah but for me that's like getting
full without eating yeah that's so
annoying yeah that's like oh I'm so full
what did you eat I don't know it's like
Souplantation yeah yeah yeah so it's
like why are you gonna most people wanna
not get a girl pregnant and have have a
lot of sexy yeah so true but that's
that's crazy what a heck he doesn't have
to pay child support or didn't at least
when it was a secret I mean if that was
his goal he probably could have died
happy he probably [__] crashed
himself yeah dude and the irony the
irony goes on and on and on in the story
yeah so he built what's called a Whitman
W5 Buttercup airplane
Buttercup so I'm seeing a pink thing
Buttercup dude sounds like it's floral
like when I jerk it
it's called you know the baby butter
right yeah you call it the baby the
butter right there that's a baby butter
yeah and I say and then my wife's ear
here
immediate ecstasy usually
second climax
180 seconds
Steve brings the pain maybe it registers
on the Richter Scale if if director
skill is attached to my bed
dude there are certain crimes that if
you get to that level like he can't
they're not gonna undo all these kids
that got born so he's pretty much what
they should is that what you're saying
[Laughter]
kids oh dude they're gonna they're gonna
make like thousands so his DNA is like
Genghis Khan competition exactly oh on
this level yeah this global scale like I
guess my dad's name is Morris Workman
have you guys ever thought about having
a lot of kids not really
no not really not since I learned about
the world depopulation plan yeah I'm
like yeah why would I bring them up why
would you want that but like what more
condom like what if he just birtheded
Jesus what is it what is it that you
think is happening in the mind of a guy
because I know there's a lot of dudes
like this what do you think is the thing
that's happening that makes them want to
just impregnate everybody you know that
like that because cream pies feel good
dude
but like
they don't want birth control as part of
the equation they want to have a kid
yeah like what makes that that's true
vanity yeah is it vanity you think it's
like to make make more of yourself yeah
yeah you're cloning you're the cloner
you're the guy at the party and all
these [__] should be with me yeah
yeah they don't care about their boner
they care about cloners yep cool thank
you yeah
we're gonna license that [__]
it's big bucks man you want to print
that underneath your cups at bored and
hungry don't even try it we got you on
camera the John 316 yeah they don't care
about boners they care about cloners oh
I never noticed yeah and then that's at
the fertility clinic it's the
catchphrase yeah all the way around the
world and fan base like you're saying
easy I always thought that was an
interesting thing it is dude it is like
a guy that just wants a lot of kids
because there's dudes that have that
like ready to go they're like they want
to just get girls pregnant yeah there
was that guy that Japanese guy that was
doing that in Thailand remember you got
caught with like
like 50 kids or some [__] and he had
like a whole lot like Haram do you kind
of wanted your own Army though is that
where it kind of comes from maybe
I got a little Squad right here maybe
it's like I can't trust anybody unless
they're in my family yeah so I have to
make a lot of people in my family but
the chances are yeah but if you ever
came from like any family you know like
there's a lot of them that you just [__]
I wish they weren't around dude in the
glossary in the glossary of phobias is
there a phobia for being the last of
your bloodline no
because that's what that [__] looks like
to me yeah like there's a fear of like
it'll end with me so I need to get my
sperm out he's like I might be the last
of the Mohican yeah don't you think like
you have that many kids the quality
control of like having those kids
they're just not gonna be like that cool
you know as they get older because like
think about all the Care the attention
you have to give to like one kid and
then you have like five kids five years
in a row it's like
no way let's ask the Mormons because
they make successful people but they
stay in the lives of those kids right
yeah yeah they're not like Nick cannony
and just having bomb ass Christmas gifts
I got a PS5 again how do you have if you
have a hundred kids right yeah let's go
lower say 20. dude
you spend once a day with one of them
that's only a third that's already a
third of the Year imagine if you had
five taikas oh I that's one two three
four five like imagine if you did it
back to back or say two years and
they're all crank calling you and prank
calling you guys are crazy
different states are they Max I could
have is two or three attackers I think
yeah that guy's nuts
like it's just a guy you met you think
if you had like three more kids no you
don't want three more kids do you want
are you working out more
I I'll be okay really but like in a
couple years though right oh if I knock
it out sooner than later yeah yeah oh
that's true yeah that's true are you
gonna knock it out what do you do yeah
what's your move what's your thing
what's the Clones
hey can I ask you this do you remember
like the night that you can see each one
are you like I know exactly what we did
no do people normally remember that yeah
that's why some kids are named Mercedes
yeah or like Vegas names
Sahara
meet Henderson
Henderson because they did it now this
is Prim and this is Henderson
for him oh my God this is Buffalo Bill
over here this is Peggy suit this is
physics this is Fort Apache
[Music]
foreign